[Music]
three two one action
hey guys welcome back to off the record
where we talk about whatever we've got
welcome to the show Mort okay are you so
nervous your name hey spell their name
mo Tok way it sound exactly okay
yeah it's Japanese Japanese are you uh
is your mom or dad Japanese yeah I fall
along the stereotypical mom is Asian and
that is why is your mom from Japan or
yeah straight up so they actually met in
Japan it's a really cute story is your
dad military no so you're not that
stereotypical
no that's true this is true it wasn't
like Okinawa or anything they met
teaching English together so your mom
taught English in Japan yeah so I got
assigned to an assignment together and
then Here I am
are you advocate English he's got double
English pants I know we should be
[ __ ] good yeah I should teaching you
should be the master speller of all time
pretty much okay go test them throw word
it will put them to the test
easy thank you damn damn did you get in
trouble if you didn't get an A in
English so you're like that is our pride
it's mostly like math if you like that
makes sense right you got to continue
the pedigree man I got older brother
older sister feels like we're all dating
you right now teal yellow oh you like
steel I mean what's your favorite movie
5050 with Joseph gordon-levitt oh that's
a good one well can't wait let's have
someone another question while we can
judge him hard
yeah when are you on over to your
astrological sign yeah yeah yeah Sat
said saggitaron
okay cool
there we go I don't know you guys
believe in that [ __ ] no his wife does
like a [ __ ] mother she talks
about Mercury retrograde whatever that
is I full-on couldn't buy a house when
we were gonna buy one because it was
Mercury retrograde and I thought it was
too funny to fight it
that's mercury right retro that it gets
when the planets align a certain way
like you're not supposed to make big
decisions or like make crazy big
purchases because then like everything's
all misaligned and some bad she's coming
so did she have a telescope to see that
the planet you don't need that anymore
Bart we're not in the [ __ ] 1700 is
she a fan of Galileo I'm just looking up
online now well how do you trust I'll
know Janine co2 naked I know you could
do come apart no it's that naked eye
ball because you said you use the
telescope what the [ __ ] yeah but yes
she's very in and that stuff so I always
enjoy I like your episodes with her when
she's doing some crazy [ __ ] what would
she do oh she was trying to persuade
great Gary on a grande right to come
back she was trying to save our pet
grasshopper we have a pet grasshopper
named Gary on engrossment badger cat
hasn't even eaten tell me about I can't
believe good things alive we've had it
since last June it's still in our
[ __ ] long does grasshoppers survive
yeah it doesn't make any sense so okay
so how do I know what you saying what is
it is it's the same exact [ __ ] one
okay one year so it's coming I'm not
even kidding you this is a long life for
us this is getting mystical and [ __ ] for
me okay so so our cat gets outside
yesterday and he goes right up to the
plant where Gary is and he starts
[ __ ] eating it like he's a little
animal I just can't wait to eat stupid
[ __ ] and then Gary like takes off and
flies using her wings or whatever and
she goes like into the stairwell but in
our back yard and then she's like oh
[ __ ] and then we get the cat inside and
then I'm like Nicky you just gotta leave
her alone because she's gonna do what
she's gonna do and there's nothing we
can do like she's not going back to that
[ __ ] Bush because she doesn't she's
too stupid she's no yours
and then Nikki's like hold on so so so
she goes and gets a jar and she goes
outside and she she Tom talks to Gary
for like eight minutes she was like on
the floor on her knees it's talking to
it I'm a good friend and I follow your
guys's [ __ ] yeah I got pretty bored of
watching her talk to it after like four
minutes okay 30-second timeout
I missed the next part which is pretty
insane okay so she after talking to it
Harry turned around and then Nicki stuck
the jar down and Gary hopped immediately
into the jar and Nicki returned it to
the bush where it hop off and it's now
come back in the book so thick ready to
eat hey dude I don't even know what that
reference is but yes it's like really
it's a good movie
you're not the big Disney person not the
big guy yeah I don't see though it's a
good movie though you should check her
that even the way like she made a
connection with Gary on a crime he liked
it was through a jar because in like she
turned the jar and then look it's
exactly like right in to me except I
like rats better than grasshoppers rats
are pretty cool yeah I just feel like
because I'm such a skeptic about all
this [ __ ] and all the [ __ ] Virgo she
had Lanza Gary skeptic for a long time
but that she got it back on the bush
yesterday I'm blown the [ __ ] away like
she's got some kind of a weird
connection with his [ __ ] grasshopper
are you getting jealous no I just think
it's [ __ ] odd and my life is a sitcom
well that the connections about to end
soon I know ya ready cuz she go cross
where have you heard of a grasshopper
this is in the same place for like seven
months or some [ __ ] and they have wings
and it can fly and it doesn't fly away
that's true I'll you know of a jiminy
right maybe that's what grasshoppers do
know they don't think they de l'opéra
hop around it you've observed Nicky told
me from cheetahs reach they don't have
territory I don't [ __ ] know dude I
don't know like fighters I don't care
enough to look it up I just know from
what non-serious isn't if he in love
with the grasshopper she know it's her
pet grasshopper and so like buddy Oh
it's not sexual with you oh I thought
maybe it was like a b-movie it's like
the B movie where the woman literally
falls in love with the B oh she had a
boyfriend and then the [ __ ] boy from
the movie with Jerry Seinfeld wait while
I miss B movie but that's so a woman
falls in love with an insect the B yeah
think about that she's like I think they
got married and [ __ ] yeah with this man
it's real-life human it's actually a
documentary I mean there's so many weird
things that people get married to
yeah there's that lady that got married
to the wall don't laugh at me that got
married to the San Diego train station
she was rubbing her ass on the [ __ ]
train station she was she just loves the
energy of the train station yeah yeah I
mean there's another lady that married
Eiffel Tower same thing that's these are
all just like euphemisms like you
getting railed on a train I'm drew you
know I flip the eiffel tower so it's all
sexually phallic symbol so true yeah
that's true you're gonna say you never
had any pets you [ __ ] I was like wow
that was that's a job are you never had
one pet growing up that one no mother
would not let me yeah see so you guys
made you guys live in apartment no well
I guess a little bit part of the part of
my life in Japan probably that's cool he
lives in Japan too we're not there no so
I lived in Ohio for four years when to
Japan you had to Ohio from Ohio
I went from Ohio to Ohio to
ohayo-gozaimasu yeah exactly
I've been I moved back to New York good
old Ohio [ __ ] Ohio never go there really
what part we don't love us no oh god
it's like a Juggalo land is it yeah I'm
just kidding
Insane Clown Posse to Los Angeles three
and a half years ago for college yeah
from Ohio I went to Loyola Marymount on
the west side and I dropped out says oh
I know where that's at did you drop out
for you to kind of acting all the same
that's cool man that's a good choice you
well I don't know anymore cuz I just
came from my audition which is why I was
late by the way sorry you animations
always make people lame
it was a call back and I walk into the
room right it's pitch dark and there's
the director from tag yeah it's pretty
good and then like okay please take off
your shirt okay it's for a deodorant
commercial he's doing porn okay yeah
there's like a dozen people in there I
can't see their faces cuz it's dark yeah
is that the guy with the camera you know
like yeah yeah it's just creepy smiling
is there I take your dick off charge
shirt jerking off yeah likewise topic in
the wrong room like all [ __ ] oh that the
order that's next door block this is the
jerk-off video bro yeah this is porn huh
man well if it did get weird because I
was I was there and they're like okay
now this next scene kind of has a I
don't know if I'm allowed to talk about
it who cares they're like it's like a
hypnotic nipple part so kind of like you
know do your thing I was like what
hypnotic nipples I was just like okay
cool so I was assuming it's a physical
comment you didn't get like asides for
the problem it's literally three lines
oh man there's like breaks in between so
he's just like yeah do something with
your nipples what are you like that
hypnotized me with your nipples is what
they said actually and I don't know what
that means so I'm what did you do you're
getting sleepy so I'm literally in some
guy's garage and I'm doing this
deodorant like what the fun's weird I
was just like gyrating a little bit you
know
weird no no is anybody getting
hypnotized
I wish the girls like this did you hear
this yeah that was really awkward but
it's it last because he would have me do
the same thing over and over he's like
now do it like less sexually-charged
more normal I'm like I'm generating my
nipples like how do you do you do that
in like a normal setting yeah everyday
you normal I like normally hypnotize
something with your nipples like that's
just do that yeah yes just don't you
know they don't even know either so they
want you to come up at the end towards
the guys trying to figure out how to
hypnotize people with their nipples not
asking any women about it at all who
actually do it and have done for a
living by the way like [ __ ]
that's true yeah so how do you think it
went
on the whole it was alright I think my
nipples were pretty perky so I don't
know if like they're looking for certain
comedy or if they're like actually just
like looking for a certain look you
never tell you huh yeah they never tell
if this is a callback what was the first
audition oh yeah the first audition I
also took off my shirt but I just did
the lines like a normal person they
didn't say anything weird about it it's
like we like the guy with the nipples
man but what I thought was interesting
is you're not allowed to ask actors to
improvise cuz that's illegal because
technically you're you're inviting them
to give you ideas you know what I mean
for like that's like literally free
labor
that's improvising they just have to say
it in like a weird way like you know
whatever you want to do you know what I
mean like very sly about it oh I didn't
know that
because I can get fine though apparently
I don't have know the actual rules but
poke your nipples but normally stroke
your nipples are the way you would do it
whatever you want to do yeah we have
other weird auditions that probably like
it ranks the top like weird yeah that's
definitely the weirdest I've never had
to take off my shirt did you feel like
you needed a shower afterwards no I came
immediately for sure yeah yeah more so
for this yeah yeah
why have you had any weird audition no
but I've actually been on the other side
of that we're we're casting people and
that's always very interesting do you
ask them the same things like no it's
just more like um it's really it's that
awkward thing because I've been on both
sides of that fence now but late more
lately I was on the the casting side of
the fence and so it's so interesting to
have people come in and like and like do
the [ __ ] with you or it's like hey
yeah yeah yeah yeah and then they're
like I love this mic not thanks and
everyone says that so you don't even
give a [ __ ] anymore like at first you
dick gets kind of hard because of that
and then by the end of the day you're
like yeah okay whatever I know you don't
even care you just want the gig yeah so
um but then somebody they could go a
little extra with it like because they'd
a read on a website just before they got
there that to make try to make up
personal connections so they start to
say something specific there they read
about the script that they love about
this graph so it just gets to that point
where your soul dies too and I didn't
realise that like that you forget that
like when you go to an audition cuz you
just sat in traffic for an hour and a
half and then you go in there and you're
in there for 30 seconds and then you're
out like you always like man
course they treated us better right put
it on the other side of that fence
you've seen like 300 people today and
you're like I'm so [ __ ] hungry and
I'm supposed to be in this little tiny
room and [ __ ] everything I'm just trying
to have the same conversation with
everybody it's really weird
I'm always curious what happens in
between when the actors go in and out
like all the casting directors like
talking mad [ __ ] you know man they're
like oh he was god-awful if somebody's
got awful then there's nothing else to
do but conduct their lap or just be like
wow we're like like one of those but but
the room that I was in was pretty
respectful like it wasn't like [ __ ] that
guy or anything it was just gauging the
performance because you're actually
genuinely trying to find
match for the pearl alright so maybe you
look at each other like now or you're
like are you like oh yeah I like that
yeah that kind of [ __ ] it's not yeah
damn and a stupid fat ass or anybody
like I'm still in the room sir yeah
exactly it's weird though it's always
awkward I remember um our buddy was
getting like Craigslist performers to do
his little short and we were in his
little one-room apartment and
auditioning and there were some people
that came in for the read and it looked
at everything in their life I'm sorry I
can't do this and they walked out why
cuz it's like a janky-ass yeah as I do
beneath them yeah I can see why though I
can see why now but back then I was like
how dare they who do they think they are
I had auditioned babies once that was
fun how do you audition of baby our
movie internet-famous what I had work
with the baby
so it was like more hated you for life
she hated me for every year because I
had to scare her the whole time so um
while we're doing casting like the
babies would come in and like you you
kind of try to talk to the baby and [ __ ]
but like what the baby you don't they
just start crying every single one
starts crying writing and so the ones
that kind of don't like just [ __ ]
immediately start crying or like dude
yeah then you're like okay that was damn
bad I guess look you don't know but then
I had a bit were like I was like oh that
babies - oh yeah [ __ ] right like [ __ ]
like that you just you just do the same
Hollywood [ __ ] like that baby's not
gonna just to make it fun yeah cuz you
don't know what else to do it's just so
awkward you're auditioning babies so
stream I want to hold auditions because
I'm trying to find that next William
Hung yeah next one you know a little
karaoke night yeah all over town karaoke
yeah I'm gonna discover him the next
William hog that's I mean just look in
the mirror bro mmm not really
yeah but he's too self-aware he's
looking for a guy who doesn't know oh I
can act the part but it's not as funny
the guy who doesn't know what he's doing
who thinks he's killing it yeah that's
what it now that's that's gold
that's real entertainment yes
for that guy it's not because they want
to be a star I'm gonna make their dreams
come true yeah you're laughing Adam
where he's like he's like really
passionate he thinks he's a [ __ ] so
that's what that's exactly what we just
said we need that that's like tommy was
alright like yeah the whole thing about
the room like that's what makes it so
great yeah you want them to like think
they're really [ __ ] dope and you want
to blow up their ego yeah and you want
them to be famous everyone clapping well
all the joke together like yeah you're
so [ __ ] good and then they get even
more and more into this like big [ __ ]
that's the should I do to Tycho to like
boost them up and like have him do it
yeah see you do the same thing
well because he's dumb right now right
but we want to do that to like a 30 old
man yeah it's just a number you know
yeah I just want to build a guy I think
it's fun year the older they are what do
you guys think of parents that take
their kids and like auditions like maybe
even though we do that they're so young
right okay I'm actually interested in
that world but I just don't even know
how the lay into it yeah yeah we were
interested in it too but then like we
even got headshots for him and
everything but we never like remember
that photo shoot as it did with Darion
like on the fence yeah that was always
against the fence but yeah we never did
anything with it because I was always
kind of like I don't know if he wanted
to do it then I kind of felt kind of
weird about it too yeah like they're
working then and they're so young yeah
but they're not the passion about it
because people play pretend all the time
like in front like in the front of the
house like their Playhouse or whatever
mm-hm
that's the thing I wanted to get to the
point because we he was already filmed
like he would come in a few things with
JK films back when we do skit he was
getting a little never memorize the
lines like I told them to can't work
with that you pick up to the sign like
you're never working this town ever
it was really like she's being obviously
like the kid right she'd be in it and
then he kind of be over it and then over
it so I'm like doing all the crafty I
don't want to be the bad guy in his life
or ever to force him to do anything
things like do we got this job we got to
make sure you know the moms are scary oh
yeah they're so into it to cut the rope
it's like the beauty pageant oh yeah
yeah what do you think of it you think
it's wrong that I think it's different
like it's a case-by-case right give the
kids into it you can definitely tell
when the moms or parents I guess sorry
how do we know the kids into it that's
like saying it's like animal testing
it's like you got a chimpanzee and
you're like you're injecting everything
like he loves it he [ __ ] eats the
bananas after he's having fun like how
do we know anything they love it I think
when the mom doesn't give a [ __ ] and she
wants she can't wait to go home and
she's just sitting there like is it over
yet that's how you know it's real like
just there for the kid yeah your pageant
moms like all that sure what do you
think of that [ __ ] or effect or if the
kid is practicing more than the mom
wants to so yeah back in the day I used
to love kung fu so much when I got hold
out going the backyard his practice
forms all day and my mom would be like
can you just switch to something else
like piano or like a [ __ ] why
aren't you just [ __ ] amazing at home
food [ __ ] math equations that's true
you should have been a kung-fu master I
really like tofu bass he's like you're
really good at that but stop that [ __ ]
here do this man funniest ancient logic
ever so I was I think I was like one of
the three youngest black belt in his
school and then he'll and then he was
telling my mom like hey I really want to
take this guy to China with me my mom's
on a roster series like cuz he wanted to
take me to China to compete
holy [ __ ] got to be really cool and he
said oh no nuts getting too serious so
you just I just need you to get a black
belt so you can put that in a College
resume now it's time to move on and do
something that's amazing wow that sucks
did that help your resume if I applied
that way but I got so much trouble that
I had to call like the JCL because it
was way different yeah I don't even know
what my parents wanted me to do they
probably call everybody
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]